on continue dans le sexe et la défonce
mais cette fois dans un milieu inattendu
le cyclisme voici willy vote
il
ça va ça va bien merci
on dit willie willie route vous êtes
belge en fait je suis belge colis cgg
pas appris le français à la capitale
démis française
j'ai appris le français dans la peur de
tomber à l'annoncé pas vous êtes
l'ancien soigneur de festina oui et donc
vous êtes occupé de virac pendant des
années vous êtes équipé de virac
et vous publiez votre deuxième livre qui
s'appelle sexe mensonges et vélo petit
vélo petit vélo c'est un roman merci
patrick gorria tripes c'est un roman qui
sort chez calmann-lévy donc en fait
c'est un roman mais c'est des faits
réels sauf le dernier chapitre vous le
préciser alors on apprend un truc
extraordinaire ça vous intéresser les
filles c'est que dans vélo il ya non
seulement des piquouse mais il ya des
partouzes c'est vrai c'est vivre ça
arrive
oui moi je savais vraiment tout le monde
sait que les cyclistes qui se défoncent
samedi matin puisqu'on attend ce qu'on
apprend dans l'herbe ou cas c'est que
non seulement ça se défonce mais en plus
ça baise à mort ça s'enfonce bravo ça se
défend
alors c'est la vie d'un jeune cycliste
qu'à 23 ans qui s'appelle arnaud faucher
évidemment tout le monde parle de vous
parce que bientôt avoir lieu à la
rentrée il ya le procès festina donc
avec vous et puis virenque a toujours
été défoncée comme il dit à l'issue de
son plein gré et vivement que ça vous a
fait du mal cette trahison parce que
vous dites c'est celui que j'ai le plus
aimé le plus aidé ça m'a fait très très
mal parce que
c'était un peu mon fils dit l'avenue
dans ce milieu un peu au hasard parce
que ce n'était pas un super à maui alors
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses pour lui
j'ai beaucoup aidé et je peux dire que
je suis pour un petit peu
qu'est ce qu'il est devenu ouais donc
dit en parlant de vie dit il a et j
quand je me suis fait arrêter
donc j'ai pensé que c'était lui comme
ils l'avaient pas mal des relations
c'est lui qui va me sentais vraiment ce
à dire que vous a pas sorti
non non il vous a trahis et vous dites
d'ailleurs en parlant de richard
virenque vous dit il en a beaucoup dans
les jambes mais pas beaucoup dans la
tête et votre fils lui il a décroché le
poster de sa chambre dernier crochète
ont fait ce qu'ils veulent faire de
miracle il a décroché et joue au foot et
je vous foutent pas des jouets
on va prendre les choses par le
commencement où il y faire une interview
vérité on ne bouge pas dans le jingle
[Musique]
bien alors vous êtes né en 45 j'ai
commencé à courir l'âge de 15 ans dans
des kermesses et tout de suite les
amphétamines a dès le début
pas tout de suite mais en fait david
alors vous dites d'ailleurs commandé en
fait on voi le mec tout petit comme ça
voilà on se sent en superman en ce sens
superman et le problème c'est quand on a
mal calculé son coup après après la
descente est difficile comme superman
après on est moyen man comme di palma
doit alors après donc à 23 ans devait
arrêter parce que votre père voulait
trop vous poussez c'est ça c'est ça il
était il croyait que tout le monde
pouvait venir champions c'est pas la cas
quoi il était pharmacien mon oncle donc
vous devenez chauffeur de car à ce
moment là et vous revenez dans le
cyclisme comme soigneur comme soin comme
soigneur alors quand on vous parle du
dopage et quand vous dites est ce que
vous croyez qu'on peut gagner cinq tours
de france à l'eau claire non alors non
débuté les en fait
et puis après ils ont arrêté à la mort
de simpson en 67 ils ont arrêté les
amphétamines on est plutôt passée du
côté des anabolisants à nouveau
envisager qu à vous parler d'un
pharmacien qui habitait à wasquehal
comme on dit pascal vous allez vous
servir chez lui passé par derrière
on passait par là et ailleurs et c'est
un autre fournisseur quoi à l'époque
c'était facile pensez bien on apprend
que le vélo c'est pire que tout voilà
moi mais ça c'est à l'époque il ya 25
ans longtemps parce qu'elle a pris il ya
eu le ps 306 cas si les petits trucs
parce que ils m'ont tout pris c'est tout
et non pas lui ça c'était le meilleur
vélo va vous appeler serre a dit la monf
un grand nom parce que je suis dis
l'heure je suis malade à cause du procès
n'ont pas dit leurs fournisseurs de dos
n'ont même pas maintenant soigneur
soigneur vous transporter vous avez du
mal à dire de vous dites je rentre je
dis pas je drague les cours et dit je
les prépare c'est très difficile de dire
si j'avais su ça c'est raide c'est très
dur dopage et non leur prépare on est si
j'avais su je me serais jamais fait
serré j'aurais dit que je faisais du
vélo j'étais con alors on n'y a pas
pensé à ça donc mais vous dites que les
coureurs il aime tellement ça faisait
mais tellement ça que j'étais obligé de
tenir les produits par devers vous parce
que sinon ils se mettaient n'importe
quoi on était là il faut faire gaffe à
ce que c'est vrai c'est un produit
surtout le dernier produit qui existe
on se sent tellement bien que voilà
alors dites moi j'attends le beurre
c'est un truc comme ça sérieusement pour
ma gouverne personnel est ce que tu en
est là c'est sérieux cette fois est ce
que les journalistes sportifs le savent
et est ce que robert chapatte le savait
ben je pense que sur tous ces gens là
l'ont su et qu'ils ont rien dit pendant
35 ou 40 ou 50 ans ils sont aussi
coupables que vous bien qu on doit tout
le respect à robert chapatte parce que
c'est ce que les gens le nom mais c'est
un ancien coureur donc qui sait de quoi
il parle donc mais c'est la légende de
ça donc mais tout le journaliste
sportive ils sont au courant qu est ce
qui se passe pas vraiment parce qu'elles
sont jamais ils sont jamais dans les
chambres pourraient ils le disent pas
les gens à l'esprit pourquoi je ne sais
pas moi j'ai jamais par les mosquées
boulot mais eux n'ont eux ils étaient la
peau pour parler du passé alors qu'on a
toujours expliqué que le tour de france
d'un truc formidable mais qui monte des
montagnes et un jour l'apprend qui sont
tous des fonds c'est formidable parce
que demain on arrête l'adobe la dope
ça sera en toujours le même qui sont
devant c'est en tous les cas je trouve
ça s'ils voulaient pour moi c'est un
petit peu comme la francisque de
mitterrand dire que tout le monde le
savait personne n'en a parlé ou l'amitié
de mitterrand pour bousquet tout le
monde le savait personne à parler en
lisant vos bouquins et puis d'autres
bouquins on s'aperçoit que les jeunes
sportifs depuis 50 ans il savait que la
dame blanche de geminiani c'était la
coke et personne n'en parlait et je
trouve qu'ils font pas leur boulot c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire je ne porte pas
de jugement moral ont peut-être peur de
perdre leur boulot à être non pas
vraiment parce que moi c'est pareil
moi j'ai commencé à parler dans ce
milieu alors en 93 vous commencé à
bosser pour festina vous allez chercher
les flacons à bordeaux qui arrive du
portugal alors votre femme quand même
bon sens des femmes elle vous dit vous
voulez dit sylvie fait de la place dans
le frigo et elle vous dit tout ça va mal
finir dans quelle votre femme attention
toujours un et alors bon vous vous parle
évidemment parler tout les docks
comprend l'oriel peau belge le pot belge
sega mélange assez pressé de poubelles
vous essayez le pot belge
il ya en dedans c'est la recette du
pont-belge c'est ce que prennent les
cyclistes ya amphétamines caféine
antalgiques cocaïne corticoïdes et on
doit être dans un ballet tard et c'est
un super speed ball et j'aurais pas
besoin de tous sa chérie ce soit alors
dans votre premier livre vous parlez de
la coco 6 et ils font le championnat
parce qu'ils sont cinglés le mec qui
font les championnats du monde de
cyclisme en colombie que font les mecs
j'y tiens
pourquoi faire les championnats du monde
de cyclisme en colombie quand on sait ce
qu'on sait non mais c'était après c'est
arrivé après après les championnats du
monde du 8 juillet 98 vous vous faites
arrêter à la frontière donc avec des
produits dopants ce qui vaudra une mise
en examen là où fait arrêter quand vous
aviez 235 dose de doper au public 82
doses d'hormones de croissance
60 doses de pente et stone que là il a
dit que c'était pour cet opus les
corticoïdes les amphétamines bon petit
quand vous passiez la frontière tout le
monde des os à lui comment ça va bien
ce jour-là vous ce jour là oui on dirait
que j'avais un sentiment
j'étais sur l'autoroute je dis qu'est ce
que je fais je pense
la frontière sur l'autoroute où je
prends le petit frontières et le dernier
moment le thème le dernier dernier
moment je quitte la route
je prends la petite route et voilà et
voilà j'ai trouvé je vois un monsieur
l'a pas cru je déjà sur le territoire
français ils m'arrêtent et bonjour
monsieur duval rien à déclaré ryan a
déclaré jeudi non pas vraiment là
c'était foutu et là je sentais que
c'était un coup monté
enfin je peux pas le dire mais j'ai le
sentiment parce que derrière les
buissons à droite de la route
il y avait caché une camionnette avec
ses douaniers ils sont 1 sortie de leur
camionnette ils ont ouvert ma voiture
ils ont enfin on peut pas le dire mais
moi j'ai le sentiment oui la sphère
festina commenter tout le monde la
connaît l'équipe était exclue virac
pleurs les coureurs abandonne enfin
voilà et le tout 798 le tour 99 vous
pensez qu'il ya eu de la défense
toujours je pense oui oui parce que
99,99
c'était soi-disant le tour prochain et
ils ont quand même fait le
moyenne le plus rapide des deux tours il
ya quelque part il y avait beaucoup de
vent je sais pas ça très bien
alors donc je disais tout à l'heure
avant de commencer qu'il ya de la
défense et de l'enfance que vous l'avez
très bien dit de très belles phrases et
autres bandits alors moi je veux pas les
votes bouquin faut le dire quoi page 43
c'est une mini par tous
page 108 c'est une bonne partout sans
capote avec carmen et page 220 c'est là
par tous j'ai expliqué qu'il campait
nous affranchir de 120 pages 220 c'est
partout avec le mari consentant un donc
ce qu'il faut savoir mon cher bruel oui
allez prendre cher boya lycée qui est
carmen carmen s'est fait partie de ses
fils et des groupies c'est comme dans la
politique c'est comme dans le show
business cd cd fille qui tourne autour
un peu comme les circuits de formule 1
sur ces défis qui suivent les coureurs à
l'agneau mari voilà elle adore les
coureurs elles vont tourner dans les
parkings autour des camions comme ça et
puis à 21h elles sont dans les chambres
d'hôtel l'essentiel pas moi je serai pas
franchement et à 22h20 tunnels sont les
couloirs et à 22 heures et sont dans les
chambres d'hôtel les carmen une il ya
plein de filles comme ça c'est à dire
que les veines avec jean mais ne
sanctionnent pas ce qu'on ne sait pas
est ce qu'on découvre dans le dans le
livre de deux villes il a dans ce
bouquin c'est qu'en fait en dehors de la
défense il ya le secteur des filles qui
veulent se taper des sportifs pour une
raison alors ça incroyable elle fantasme
sur les jambes rasé dire que le fait que
et veut pas que ça aussi qu'on défend
une fellation à son parti pour la
semaine et voulait dire que
sa mère à huy a dû testostérone
c'est vrai on remarquera mines tsx ivn
et ça laisse rêveur énorme parce que je
savais pas moi je me demande et je vais
prendre toujours déjà fait des trucs en
france quatre pattes ancien maire de
paris c'est en plein rêve pourquoi tout
le monde voulait suivre le tour voilà
chaque année on vous dit moi ma vie de
france 2 dit on c'est du tour de france
est ce que tu vois c'est sa première
année qui ma ville j'y vais chancel
pendant tout surtout ses chances et à
les payer toujours sur le tour et j'ai
compris un truc au centre ancien que
vous faites dans les villes dans les
étapes y aller il ya les ils vont il
faut que les boîtes échangistes envers
n'envoyer que c'était le tour de france
en fait c'est le tour des boîtes
échangistes de grosses basses en a pas
partout partout l'année opinion est la
bienvenue parce qu'il avait mal au cul
c'est n'avait rien à
alors quand ceux ci étaient en vie avant
disait toujours faux pas baiser avant la
course a bien sale on disait c'est pas
avec leur gonzesses trouver des produits
de niro dans raging bull avant le avant
le combat il ne veut pas hélas hélas en
fait c'est pas si hier le tour de france
où le champion du monde c'est autre
chose lui mais qui sont quand même pas
qu'on se prend là mais s'il ça vient ça
vient et c'est beau le sport est alors
les doutes révélations dans votre
bouquin est d'abord que les filles
cycliste dope aussi et alors vous aussi
pouvez vous aussi participer à ce qu'on
apprend c'est que les suiveurs il se
dope aussi c'est les mecs de la caravane
dit attends j'ai me le borgne a fait en
bagnole aujourd'hui je m'en voyez un
casier grade en fait je serai en
virginie et coralie ce n'est pas ça que
je veux savoir c'est que vous aussi ou
ville ait pu sérieusement m
vous êtes défense et vous bat bien sûr
et vous dit ma mère tu ne comprends pas
poursuit il dit maintenant je peux
mettre des chemises pulls à manches
courtes
c'est vrai la pala maintenant vous êtes
klink huawei série finalement je me suis
en sortie toute façon oui c'est ça c'est
bien je suis content oui j'aime avec un
douanier quand elle décroche un
festivalier non non on va bien sûr
douaniers
heureusement heureusement j'avais
heureusement je suis content je suis
content ce que vous dites vous en gros
je j'abrège mais en gros vous dites que
bon on va peut-être trouvé un moyen pour
voir le paie aussi ce qui va se passer
d'ailleurs maintenant là le 20 juin
bon mais vous dites qu après il ya
d'autres trucs ça sans que les gendarmes
vont toujours moins vite que les voleurs
là que finalement il ya le pfc il ya
l'hémoglobine réticulé et finalement les
mecs ils auront toujours un tour
d'avancé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
pognon
donc les mecs ils trouveront toujours
des docks que les autres ne savent pas
découvrir voilà donc ces drogues a
drogué pour toujours j'ai toujours connu
ça sur 30 ans de carrière on a toujours
essayé de saint-vaast autre chose parce
que ouais vous dites toute façon le jour
et notre solution évidemment c'est de
contrôler le dopage nous dit ce jour là
ce sera plus un sport ce sera un
spectacle spectacle mais comme aux états
unis il sera comme le shopping our own
on est là mais ça sera ça serait pas
plus mal ça sera moins dangereux
ouais bien on peut rallumer merci oui
nous sommes donc voilà
je rappelle le type de confusion
langer petit vélo les corrections de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu